well hello there reject nation it's Greg
Alba here I'm John Humphrey so you know
with Murder on the Orient Express coming
out this weekend with a huge a list cast
in kenneth branagh directing a classic
Agatha Christie novel penny booth and
three billboards movie Missouri or
something getting a 95% of rotten
tomatoes well I watched those movies
this weekend johner I could only catch
one it has to be daddy's home to the
family holiday comedy guarantee you for
sure was a Christmas comedy but
apparently it will get lucky maybe this
is the movie that will bring their
families we'll get four people checking
it says one yeah but before we hop into
this review wanting to give a shout out
to the people over at Stardust Stardust
is an app that we have partnered up with
recently and a lot of you guys have been
following us on there so thank you very
much because we post regularly
throughout the week on the Stardust app
we really love using it what that
basically allows you to do is do
30-second reactions for any film TV show
or trailer you can rate the movie so I
have like my daddy's home to review up
there's a 30 second one which is the
encompassing review and the reason I
like this app a lot is we first start
doing YouTube I came with a segment
early on like that a lot of people have
done like 30 second movie reviews and
then after a while you want to go into
more depth and started gathering your
audience how much time things yeah but
that content is still so appealing so
the Stardust app allows us to keep that
concept going yeah like here's a rough
you know idea of our thoughts and now if
you want to really get in depth and
reviews on you so download the app and
follow us first at the real rejects
anyway now if you already caught our
daddy's home to thoughts now we'll give
you a little bit more in depth opinions
about the film okay so I thought this
movie was very weird before weird before
we watch the movie I were you watched
the first daddy's home and introduced it
to Jon and I was like you know I don't
care this movie has a 31% Rotten
Tomatoes this movie's hilarious this is
like well yeah it's
those kind of shotgun blasts broad
comedies where at least some of the
scenes are probably gonna work for you
and make you laugh yeah like I left the
first daddy's home feeling I had a good
time and I made me really look forward
to daddy's home too because I really
enjoyed the hell out of the first one
this second one is stranger I think it's
because the movie immediately launches
into incredibly wacky slapstick
scenarios yeah with no real lead up to
that kind of humor Russ I thought the
first daddy's homes he's is that in the
first half and it starts getting there
and gets crazier and crazier and it
handles it'sit's a little uneven but it
still handles it for the most part
pretty well what here's the first one
jumps you in with his absurd sense of
humor but the second one jumps you in
with it's absurd physical yeah yes makes
the town funky and the editing is really
funky in this movie I kept going this
movie just doesn't flow and it's not
smooth and then it took me a while to
realize oh we're watching a vacation
family movie we're watching a Christmas
yeah it's like Christmas vacation yeah
because before the movie started they
were playing trailers for these family
man like what is this flame before
Daddy's own because the first one has
some pretty raunchy humor and there this
one dials a lot of that back and gives
you essentially a family comedy that's
pg-13 a little bit of vulgarity a little
bit it's still kind of she's a kid yeah
yeah exactly the reason I really was
excited for this movie was Mel Gibson
and as you guys know I've been a huge
supporter of Mel Gibson having to come
back since before his comeback started
really happening I thought he was a
perfectly cast actor for this film but
they have that scene that you seen the
trailer Mel Gibson's coming down the
escalator and then Martineau Berg and
we'll learn all are greeting him when do
you cut back for sweet Mel Gibson and
Mark Wahlberg you're like oh they do
look alike
actually yeah at first they didn't see
it then no no I'm seeing it in the
theater like III see it well and the
movie does make a point of showing you
the ways in which they're similar
because dusty isn't altogether unlike
that character either so you're like oh
yeah how you behave like this guy's kids
yeah it works on that level
what are the most lackluster and for me
personally I don't think it was they
were disappointing except for me is Mel
Gibson in this not because he's bad in
fact that's the problem he's kind of too
good he's kind of too realistic yeah
he's playing on a different level than
everybody else he's doing this subtle
realistic kind of comedy he says
outlandish things but really he's just
cool and calm and everything's just so
natural Mark Wahlberg is always up here
no matter whatever scene he's doing he's
always up here a little flustered is it
yeah cool the situation even John he's
always trying to entertain me and that
Mel Gibson has his raw realism his brand
of acting doesn't mesh well with the
entirety of the performers in this film
but it does work in certain scenes the
way this movie is structured is like
kind of like a playlist of scenes based
on yeah topics what I felt like was this
movie had an outlaw and they had two
separate papers one paper was an outline
of where they wanted this movie to go
with the other one was a bunch of
sketches they wanted thrown into this
movie and then they just went crazy you
could see the those index cards of them
going let's put this bit in here let's
put this random bit here they needed
like some crazy outlandish bit well
really the funniest moments in this film
are just the dialogue moments I think
the first time I truly started cracking
out loud in a scene was this one scene
involving all the dads in a thermostat
and they're just arguing with each other
that isn't pretty now that was a scene
yeah is the first scene where I was
sitting there going this is a kind of
inspired joke at least you know cuz all
these dudes are wrong and all four of
them are funny and that's oh yeah yeah
will you adjust and go this is like a
90s Christmas comedy or an 80s Christmas
comedy you can start to forgive it for
the many flaws this film has in terms of
structure and how it flows I feel like
your enjoyment or you're a stickler enos
for what it's lacking
will depend entirely on how much
disbelief you're willing to suspend
because after a certain point you know
when he's like destroyed Mark Wahlberg's
car and their entire outside of their
house you're like I don't believe you
guys another problem with the film is
that there's so many characters in here
at first the confident trailers really
appealing where do you think it's gonna
be about John Lithgow and Mel Gibson not
really getting along but then you
realize you got like four plots in this
film you got Mark Wahlberg and Mel
Gibson dealing with their messed-up
relationship and you got Will Ferrell
John Lithgow being way too intimate and
way to close his dad you got Mark
Wahlberg Will Ferrell having problems
with each other this whole side plot
with the wives that no one really cares
about what others although Will
Ferrell's wife has one hilarious moment
okay in the finale yeah yeah she has one
moment that had everyone crack up in the
theater and then you got plots with the
kids because daddy's home so it's a
whole bunch of stuff where's the first
day a really contained story about dad
versus that day you know well the thing
yeah is like on the one hand I applaud
them for paying attention to all that
cuz in a weird way I'm like I'm glad you
took the time to have make everyone have
a relationship then we're gonna keep
track of it yeah developing the most
amount it gets Kate last half it starts
to get psychological it's got this weird
like dark catharsis and like everyone
reaches their breaking yeah what kind of
movie am i won so like in a way it is
gripping because then here's the thing
though I normally would like to like a
lot of youtubers we like to lead with
what we love about the film and then go
into problems and we kind of led with
all the problems first that's the most
noticeable thing however is weird
there's a big however here there were
plenty of moments in the film that had
me laughing yeah so hard yeah and it
sporadic it like there's scenes where
you're just not gonna laugh at all the
random scenes were like this is
hilarious
the thing about both these movies is
that each time they have surprised me
with like wow that is a very hairy
or even some of the slapstick is like oh
I enjoyed that slapstick like what is
some clever writing and they do reach
the right pitch of absurdity sometime
and it is really funny still like I
still laughed more than I did in
probably I would say I definitely
enjoyed the film I prefer the first
daddy's home and Mark Wahlberg and Will
Ferrell are still the funniest my even
though you got John left got here you
got Mel Gibson I'll bet there's people
tuning in who are excited to see them
and while they're enjoyable they're
still nowhere near as funny as Mark
Wahlberg and Will Ferrell when they're
having issues with each other yeah and I
really felt bad for a lot of the
supporting cast cuz like Linda
Cardellini doesn't really get anything
to do in this movie hardly at all except
the one thing I can forgive it is it's
daddy's home so you wanna fill yeah yeah
yeah I just wish that she got to be a
character cuz I really enjoy every most
people are a caricature in this movie
until like 70 minutes into the psyche
like oh there's three-dimensional
characters it's John Cena John Cena who
gets credited before John Lithgow and
Mel Gibson in the opening title credits
Aziz John Cena barely in the film but he
has some really funny moments too so I
would say it's an enjoyable comedy like
it is not great by any stretch I took my
girlfriend and she loves just Christmas
movies she didn't know was gonna be a
Christmas movie so automatically she she
walked out loving in which she had no
desire to see this film even with Andrew
Terpening fellow patronage a shout-out
to you he he's visiting California from
Texas so we said yeah come meet us at
the theater and he watched a movie with
us and I super nice guy I love that guy
he was laughing more than all this is so
huge I would say overall I did enjoy you
know going off the fact that we did you
remove this and start us I give it two
stars but an actual I probably give this
a two and a half star rating I'd might
have enjoyed this a little bit more than
the first movie I think the first movies
a better made movie ending a completion
yeah and yeah it's it's just much more
easy to keep track of and there are
things that get too big but not insane
yeah that I recall whereas this one like
is so all over the place and so whacked
out yeah it kind of was very gripping to
me because of that especially when they
do start doubling down I'm like this is
what the family JAMA is so in a way I
appreciate it but I'm
there with you is it's sort of like a
two and a half it's very intermittent
you know yeah sometimes it's working and
sometimes I don't know and I'm usually
laughing at both of those things but for
very different reasons yeah yeah well
guys what did you think of Murder on the
Orient Express is he poor ragnerok again
this weekend
hey anybody check out those billboards
outside of those three comment below you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
please click that notification bell you
can follow us on social media all social
media links in the description box
Facebook Twitter Instagram and please
become a patronage act today
yay